well hello welcome back from lunch glad
to see so many people here um this is
actually pretty inspiring i've
been here at mit doing climate change
related things global change global
warming issues for
close to 25 years and it's it's
wonderful to see people finally rallying
behind
the longer view
to think about
what should we do as a campus to be a
role model for the world and what how
can we make our operations better
i just think it's wonderful to see so
many people enthused about this topic
and
just really rallying around the idea
that
we ourselves need to come up with the
ideas
no one's going to make it happen for us
and these are serious questions so i
just want to commend you all for taking
part
also on that note
i know i don't have time to be up here
today i spend an entire day doing this
stuff that isn't my regular job and i
know that most of you may feel that way
too so it's it's a nice personal
sacrifice that you've made
just to
take a step in this direction and as
we've heard so many times this is the
mini step the very beginning of a very
very long process so
you have to sort of gird yourself for
the thought that we're not going to
accomplish a huge amount today it's
it's a long road and
we need to have the wherewithal
so
on that note i'm very pleased to have
two and actually a third a very
distinguished guest to share with us
some of their knowledge
bert is virtual he's listening right now
and we could
see him as well and we will in a moment
when
his turn comes up he's at cornell
he will uh present
what another campus has done in the
sustainability realm
as an example but first more closer to
home
natalie is going to tell us what
her firm has found in
assessing cambridge's vulnerability and
resilience and where the risks are
and then even closer to home jim will
tell us a bit about what the campus
could do
i think i'm going to add complexity to
what you studied or discussed today you
discuss sustainability deferred
maintenance and now i'm going to talk
about the change
brought by climate and the stress it
will put on our built environment so i'm
here to present what the city of
cambridge is doing which is certainly of
interest to mit
and the city of cambridge has the
foresight to look at what will be the
stress imposed by climate
on its uh
municipality or in its city and um
they're to do that study
they're combining uh science uh to which
we are working with an expert advisory
panel with faculty from harvard
including uh faculty professor jacoby i
think that presented this morning
harvard and also we're working with
columbia university and with ipcc which
is a
scientist for climate change
what is the challenge for the city of
cambridge
it's basically
that current design criteria based on
the paths are no longer relevant and
we are need to
make new approach to understand what
will be the parameters of uh climate and
how we should build our environment for
it
and um why the city of cambridge is
doing that and what will be the
deliverable or the outcome of the
project is to understand
what would happen if the city would take
no action
and um
also to identify the physical and social
and economic asset that will be most at
risk so what we're doing basically is a
stress test for the city of cambridge
looking at what climate change could
mean for the city
this is a three-step approach
which is basically the project framework
looking first at climate projection and
scenario development doing a risk and
vulnerability assessment and the next
step which would be in a concrete
another phase to be started this summer
which would be what the city called a
preparedness plan but which is in fact
an adaptation plan
the climate projection are being done
looking at
time horizon
so this is looking at what would happen
in the 2030s and what will happen which
would is considered as the near future
and what will happen uh in 2017 which
would be a more uh you know uh distant
looking also at emission scenarios so
this is where the scenario development
is key is it's and this is the link with
sustainability which is a key point is
because that's a key question asked to
the city of cambridge if you're moving
to vulnerability assessment are you
giving up on sustainability and
mitigation and the answer is no i mean
because what is made as a decision for
sustainability and medication
mitigation will inform the scenario
development so we've been looking at
high greenhouse gas emissions scenario
and low greenhouse gas emission scenario
in terms of how they would impact the
climate
so
one aspect is obviously the sea level
rise
which is uh most discussed on the news
and within this area
we are working with massdot who is
undertaking a very advanced model of
syllable rise and storm surge which is
called adserk and
this the results are not public yet and
this is to be issued within the next
month but one of the key finding which
was kind of surprising to us as
is that
most likely the charles river dam won't
be overtopped
by 2030 which means that
there won't be flooding there's unlikely
to be flooding from the charles river
due to a hurricane
okay
that will happen sometimes between the
2050 2070 and this is where i mean the
consequence will have to be looked at
those result are not totally compiled in
final yet but that's going to be what
we're going to be looking at this spring
when these will be uh
reported but that means that for our
team and for the city of cambridge which
was another aspect of the climate
parameters which were a change in
precipitation which we thought would not
be a priority became the key factor in
what could cause major flooding within
cambridge uh between now and the 2030.
so this is looking at
climate projection you know when you
hear for example that uh the intensity
of precipitation will be increasing in
the near future
this is where and there will be more
rain
a more focused event
what does it mean and that has been one
of the challenge of our study is to link
science projection with engineering
planning and what it means for
construction so
basically
we've been looking at how what is the
10-year storm is being planned which we
call a 10-year storm which has a 10
probability of event which is happening
today it will be
the 10-year storm of the
2017 will be like the 25-year storm so
this is where those more uh
extreme event will happen more often we
had we linked uh those um the modeling
of those precipitation
with the pipe infrastructure and the
riverine flooding to show which area
will be most at risk of flooding and
what it means for mit is basically that
some area will be at risk for a kind of
a
more extent of flooding and a more
critical depth of flooding as well
and uh we did a similar study for heat
as well and this is where we look at
where there's going to be a significant
increase in heat and uh where uh the
baseline today is where you have about
11 days about 90 what about i mean 11
days about 90 degree on a time base
on a yearly basis it's going to be three
times that by 20 30 and six times that
by 2060 and then again we look at heat
island and what it it means in terms of
specific stress to specific areas of the
city and so those are area above 90
degree and this is what it looks like in
the 2030 and it's quite critical in the
2070. and again what does it mean for a
campus like uh mit is extreme events are
likely to increase in frequency
intensity and duration and precipitation
driven flooding is likely to increase in
frequency as well and again that sea
level rise will be less of an impact in
the near future
then what it means for the vulnerability
and risk assessment what we did is we
identify critical asset and resource
for what is the built environment and
what is the social environment looking
at public health and vulnerable
population as well as economic impact
and this is where we looked at the
climate projection
we look at on a gis base the critical
asset we overlay one on top of the other
this is for us it was really important
to translate in concrete term what
flooding meant in terms of the
scientific projection to the reality of
the terrain so this is where gis has
been a very useful tool and then we use
a standard kind of vulnerability
assessment which looking at exposure the
contact to the hazard the vulnerability
which is the function of the asset of
the sensitivity of that asset to its
adaptive capacity so uh and then the
risk which is basically a function of
probability of occurrence and the
consequence of failure
basically what we did is we had kind of
a spreadsheet for each of these assets
and i'll take the mit power plan for
example that is uh
it's exposed to flooding according to
our map what we look is that sensitivity
because for example we assume that if
critical equipment is exposed to even
six inch of flooding
it is uh it will be damaged
because we don't know mit that well we
assume there were no adaptive capacity
for example pumps or they would be flood
shutting door that would protect that
consequently it's a high risk uh because
of the impact on mit and what would be
the consequence you know so and that is
a high risk because it's the 10-year
event so we did that kind of detail
analysis
because we believe in metrics like mit
for all of the system within the city we
also extended that to the economic
analysis looking at what would happen if
real estate was damaged by flooding but
again one thing we found out is the
direction of economic activity would be
much greater
than property damage so for example if
there's flooding within the kendall
square area or there's flooding within
research and development
industry what would be the loss in terms
of people not being able to access their
job those buildings being shut down for
a day for two days what will be the
implication
we also look at public health because
it's a key aspect
north and northeast city are much
less well equipped than southern city to
cope with heat
their impact on people with chronic
disease and with vulnerable population
so that's one aspect we're gonna looked
at and also what are the implications
for indoor quality uh if you have
repeated flooding for example and you
have mold within your building so then
the challenge for us is to compile all
of these data and understand where
should be the high priority area within
the city and basically this is where and
this is work in progress we are in the
process of compiling all this
information but this is looking at
vulnerable population the economy can
impact and all the critical services and
the key finding are basically that
within the near future there should be a
focus on the
heat increase what will be the demand on
the building and what will be the impact
on the population and also
the
possibility of disruption of economic
activity as well as there will be major
impact on most infrastructure caused by
flooding and some heat as well
so my apologies this is a lot to push
through for 15 minutes
there will be a public meeting on march
17 at mit as well and the information
will be available online also as we are
submitting those report but in a
nutshell this is uh you know kind of a
summary of a very extensive study and
we're working with the sustainability
group as well thank you
okay well terrific and
thanks
very much for this invitation julie and
team and also to follow uh this
presentation that natalie has given for
us and and continue really along some of
the same themes of resilience and this
was my
charge was to talk about resilience on
campus and what might be called
resilient campus design
for those
portions of the campus that are being
kind of taken up in fresh new ways but
also for some of the types of renewal
questions that tony raised
earlier so i'm going to start out with
an
image of some campuses under different
situations on the left hand side you
might recognize
stanford
and the 1906 earthquake
um upper middle uh probably less
familiar but this is the library at
colorado state university
in 1996
the flooding that they had
and colorado state university has one of
the very best hydrology and water
resources management programs in the
country
uh you know really one of the the top
and yet their library proved vulnerable
uh the basement portion of it cal state
university northridge for the
northridge earthquake in the 90s there
this was the type of perhaps flood
storm water event that natalie was
referring to
i think it was the 2010 event uh not a
major
uh in terms of uh damage but it
perhaps an indicator and wake up for us
and then the hurricane sandy
uh that uh
is an image in the bottom central of the
nyu medical research laboratories
and many of their uh experiments
involving animal experimentation wiped
out
so it's sobering to see what's possible
when with things one doesn't expect
and with shorter types of
lead times than climate change so that
one has to think even as we've had to
think in the past couple of weeks
about the types of unusual events that
that might confront juan and it's
surprising to me on reflection that our
campus has to shut down north all the
kind of emphasis on edx mitx moocs and
so on that we can't just have classrooms
running with the kinds of snowstorms
that we've had recently
that that should be something of
closures of the past they cost an
enormous amount in terms of disruption
of academic schedules anybody who ran
monday seminars this semester has got a
mess on their hands
and we all had messes on our hands every
time one thinks about global climate
change i find in my own experience it's
when my roof starts leaking my basement
starts flooding pipes are bursting in my
own home and i have to kind of uh
balance the emphasis on long-term sorts
of change with resilience to unexpected
events and surprises
um
how is resilience used as a concept here
in the mit community what sorts of uh
ways do we think about this concept and
and to do this i did a search of the
attack
and the most frequent reference is
really to the perseverance of students
to the types of support that
the university community provides that
kind of helps to enable resilience
amongst its community
and in the face of both
regular stress but then also real
traumas
uh
and
we've got some listed here
and then the secondarily the types of
systems or infrastructure resilience
that uh occur periodically with the
cyber attacks
network resilience
our steam distribution system was a
cited wants along with electrical grid
outages that affect uh what happens on
campus this is resilience is also used
in ordinary language with respect to
these events as it is with respect to of
economics especially after the 2008
um
shock
to the economy and then finally sports
team performance were they resilient or
not in uh coping with a uh
being behind or uh defeated at one
occasion so this is the the ordinary
language and what's surprising about it
is how we don't have much discussion in
our
news on campus of climate change
resilience or of disaster resilience
doesn't come up as part of the
ordinary language on campus and the way
it does in some of our
courses and the research that we're
doing and so it's worthwhile i think to
kind of just distinguish several
concepts of resilience and how they
contribute to
what might be envisioned for campus the
most common widespread would be more
what i would call mechanical ideas of
resilience the ability to return to a
prior state or some acceptable
equilibrium sometimes it's in
engineering systems work it's time to
of restoration of the system to a prior
state
the ecosystem resilience field that buzz
hollings and others really pioneered uh
a generation ago uh
stressed and introduced concepts of
adaptation both ecosystemic and
evolutionary adaptation but also
behavioral types of adaptation
within
within ecological systems and then
the whole
modes of interaction between human and
ecological systems that that field of
conservation ecology has contributed
uh the whole field of
resilience
in
work on uh
in positive psychology and social
psychology how do societies cope with
anticipate prepare for are they
pre-adapted or not to uh different types
of stresses shocks traumas
uh is
enormous field of research and disaster
psychology and disaster sociology
ah thanks
um and then finally in the design field
which is uh our own in the uh department
of architecture school of architecture
and planning
here we don't want to return to a prior
system at all
in fact we're not even satisfied with
adaptation to a shock we want it better
we want to be much better in how one
builds back or builds in anticipation of
potential risks
i won't go through an elaboration of
this only to say that we offer courses
in disaster resilient design and the
types of
contributions that design can make to
mitigating risk
retrofitting systems large-scale
retrofits we've looked at in
other parts of the world
reconstruction after disaster
resettlement of vulnerable populations
that's going to be a topic in our
coastal cities for sure commemorative
design and we have an example of this
with the sean collier memorial coming up
right now on our own campus and really
the comprehensive approach that one
would urge uh integrates all of the
above of these different approaches or
aspects of
resilient design we've done this in
japan in india and pakistan this is a
short course in pakistan that we
run and we're complex emergencies that
are really compounded by
civil strife and
and war or
and refugee populations uh really make
these uh assessments extremely uh
uh difficult uh we've done
collaboration with the national
academies disasters roundtable
but we haven't done anything uh with
respect to at least in my
sphere with
disaster resilience on campus or climate
change resilience on campus and
fortunately it's really great to hear
about the work that the
city is doing and the office of
sustainability and so many other
colleagues here on the
vulnerability and preparedness of mit
for different types of scenarios of
sea level rise flooding and heat stress
what we have done is look at some of the
more
oh
i'll call them resilience to
more anticipated types of uh events and
some of them in a very natural pattern
of stormwater
series
as well as unusual types of stormwater
events and and come up with some
proposals on the
this slide here of a watershed
entrepreneurship approach in the east
campus
uh
design
context that is so exciting right now on
campus and this so this is an example of
someone who's trying to couple this
engineering systems and ecological
systems approach and other students who
had a really fabulous mid-rise buildings
with complex
programming of multiple residential and
mixed commercial types of use buildings
suggested that in east campus one could
have a ground plane that was committed
to a restorative environment takes some
of the edge off the psychological and
social stress of everyday life as well
as the kinds of shocks one can
experience
i'd like to stress the importance of
looking at other centers
and
berkeley is a great example of
collaboration between the
city of berkeley and the university
in retrofitting
city and campus
pretty comprehensively mary camario was
the architecture faculty member who
helped lead that really impressive
body of work that they did to undertake
a very large scale retrofit of the
university and i knew colleagues there
they used to say i really don't like to
talk with mary
you know every time i do i get worried
and so
i'd prefer but fortunately mary kept
talking and talked to the right people
in the administration and the city and
they really have a much safer campus now
if you ask where are the centers of
research for all hazards preparedness
for resilience of a comprehensive nature
it'd be really fun to do a sample we
don't have time because i just hit my
two-minute mark or so um but the sample
would it yield in your mind
these universities
carnegie mellon perhaps for risk
perception and communication but
some of the top texas a m
university colorado boulder particularly
for the climate resilience type of work
as well as hazards
delaware for disasters pen for insurance
and risk university of south carolina
the best all-around hazards program in
the country in my view and how many
people look to university of cali south
carolina
as a model for what we should be
thinking of and also learning from
really want to urge that type of work as
well as attention to what homeland
security is doing with its university
collaboration and campus resilient pilot
projects they have a
sponsored programs of investment
co-investment
to help make campuses specifically more
resilient to the types of climate
change the other
great resources on campus and when one
takes what that
homeland security approach program has
called a whole campus approach to
resilience the core core resources are
in
uh
already on campus in the safety and
security facilities campus planning mit
medical environmental health risk
management procurement student affairs
campus housing
office of sustainability not last or at
least
to say that the uh the kind of knowledge
of resilience uh amongst these
organizations is what those of us in the
research and teaching fields need to
draw upon collaborate with in order to
really advance both our fields of work
and the practice here on campus can't
happen otherwise
uh last slide then is to uh
or rather a couple of uh
questions uh
for you and
oh rats okay so that uh image that you
had on the end blocked out two questions
that i thought would be useful for
discussion and the last two questions uh
that i'll just read read them out then
is to ask how can the and i'm going to
specifically stress the outdoor campus
the campus landscape it's enviro kind of
environment outside the buildings become
leading research and teaching
laboratories for resilient planning and
design i feel like we've got made a lot
of progress on building science building
technology but as an environmental
system
the campus could be a great laboratory
and that opportunity i think beckons
enormously
and the second question would be
how can resilience become
uh not a risk management question not
necessarily solely a
constraint on design
uh to be sure one is in compliance with
risk standards of design but rather a
visionary principle for campus planning
and design where the resilience that one
has is something you're especially proud
of especially inspired by and especially
want to share is something that can
uh
ensure the well-being in all respects
of uh the campus community
uh its
uh creatures and its uh uh
larger science and legacy long into the
future
those are the thoughts on resilience in
campus planning and design really
grateful again to be included in this
and to
looking forward to the
prospects for working with
all the different groups on campus that
are a already doing this and b have a
sense of what might might happen thanks
very
well much for inviting me i'm very uh
sorry that i wasn't there to participate
all day
um flight was canceled uh i was hoping
to participate for several reasons one
just to contribute to your efforts but
two to learn
more about what you're doing
we're all kind of each university has
our own path
it's time for cornell to sort of reset
our
approach to sustainability on campus and
throughout our academic mission we've
kind of over the last
six to eight years
developed governance and approach and
processes that need to be reset
we're getting a new
president our president david scorton uh
stepping down on june 30th going to be
the secretary of smithsonian institution
uh we're getting a new president we'll
get a new provost this summer we have a
new director of campus sustainability
and
and all our governance structures are
really time to reset so i'm gonna i'm
really anxious to hear how you make out
today and now follow up with julie
this is kind of a flip side to
adaptation and resilience i'm going to
talk mostly about mitigation
it's our story here at cornell
and
it'll be different in every university i
think i just hope that all our stories
when we look back from sometime in the
future
we we do the right things that as soon
as we can do them for uh mitigation of
carbon emissions and uh to prevent
global climate change
so i'm going to tell our story um and
it begins back in
with this picture which was taken in
i was on actually vacation it was a
quiet spring i was on vacation off in a
barrier island off the coast of south
carolina not much happening
no internet connectivity i don't think i
had a cell phone
little did i know it but there was a
takeover of our administrative building
by the students
and you can see here i don't know if you
can see my pointer toyota now
and uh
students took over the administration
building basically occupied it wasn't
the word that was used back then
and demanded sustainability and demanded
cornell comply with the coyote protocols
um
we came back
to
this headline i'll let you i'm just
going to pause for a second and let you
read this
so uh this this happened again
i came back to this and all of a sudden
cornell had committed to the toyota
protocol reductions because as you may
recall president clinton had signed the
coyote protocol in late in his term in
the late 1990s and
the united states senate and george bush
and the house failed to ratify
the protocol so
uh cornell signed up to do the creative
protocols and that was sort of the
beginning of our goal setting
in that kind of messy
conflict resolution way
so
we signed up for that and then in 2007
david squarten uh committed to the
campus to be carbon neutral by the year
2050. uh there's a big push then
by
the american college and university
president's climate commitment
actually founded by second nature and
others
to have campuses sign up i think there's
almost 700 campuses signed up for this
so we were one of the founding
institutions that signed up for that
and then 2014 came and a faculty senate
resolution
called for two things one is a
divestment from fossil fuels by our
endowment and two was to accelerate
climate uh neutrality to 2035. so our
president in consultation with the
trustees said no to divestment of fossil
fuels but yes to
um accelerated uh
carbon neutrality uh action to get us
off of fossil fuels at that point i said
whoa
that's uh that's only 20 years from now
and
that's
daunting uh because i know how long it's
going to take to
completely
transform an infrastructure that's based
on very cheap fossil fuels
so we came and said we're not we in
facilities cannot be doing this alone
needs broad campus ownership
uh specifically by academic leaders
we've engaged our colleges through a
think big
red that's uh our art where the big red
big big lip green program
we've um
we have a new budget model and um
actually i just came in today i'm going
to show you the headline here i don't
know if you can see that but
it's provost to slash budgets across
cornell university
to address 55 million annual deficit
trial ages we'll see cuts totaling 27
million
it's part of this new budget model where
everything is decentralized so there's
quite a lot of
consternation about budgets right now
it's kind of a hard time to
take a new initiative on that might cost
money that will cost money but we're
asking for academic leadership uh in
this effort
and the only way we're going to make
this i think is if
there isn't a tie-in to the academic
mission
we had a
working group of faculty and staff work
on this problem of acceleration here are
some of the
recommendations i won't go through meech
but typically we're looking for stronger
academic partnerships
and
aggressive uh investment in energy
conservation and
uh
ex in addition to adding a price of
carbon to utility bills to colleges and
units
and adding price of carbon to business
travel which many
several universities are considering and
many corporations actually do
that's not happening right now based on
that headline i just showed you
but it's it's uh under study
i'd like to go through our strategy
right now
we're trying to minimize growth that's
not going to we're not going to
eliminate it
we're going to reduce energy demand
while we where we can
and then make up the supply decarbonize
our
energy supply both electricity and heat
about 50 percent of our energy goes into
electricity in about 50 percent into
heat
and then what we can't
reduce we'll have to offset
this is a little chart of where we've
been
in 2008 that was our first greenhouse
gas inventory
submitted to the
president's climate commitment the blue
bar is the on-site fossil fuel
combustion which was coal
cornell had been primarily
coal-fired since our founding in 1865.
so we heated the campus
with coal-fired
steam through a steam distribution
system a legacy system
and
mostly procured our electricity from the
grid
of
the new york state
electric grid and that's the carbon
footprint from that we also included in
our inventory commuting by employees to
work and students
daily commuting and
air travel for work purposes
now we were able to reduce this to by
2012 by
33 percent and mainly because we went
off coal
and instead of separately procuring
electricity we went to very efficient
natural gas fired combined heat and
power so we make all the electricity uh
in-house and we make all our steam
in-house and it's more efficient so
pretty big win there
i believe mit's system is is much like
ours is now
mit didn't have the opportunity to go
off coal so not the uh the big win that
we had here
um
we bumped up a little in 2014 as you can
see that's primarily cold weather
related because of more heating
degree days
on the demand side
what we're looking at now is continuing
to keep our
building energy demand from rising this
chart shows from the year 2000 to 2014
uh the campus has grown to over 14
million square feet
about a 20 percent increase
and the buildings are listed there and a
lot of most of them are high-tech
energy hogs basically the labs we build
are 150 000 btus per square foot per
year because of so much ventilation to
keep the labs
series
safe but throughout this growth we've
been able to keep our steam
use and demand flat as you see here in
the red bars and the
left-hand axis is the million btus in a
year
or we've kept our electric use
flat and are chilled water and that's
through a very aggressive energy
conservation initiatives in existing
buildings and doing the best we can with
new buildings to make them
reduce their energy use intensity
here's a little cartoon of our campus
and i want to walk through our supply
side plans now so this is our campus
it's 14 million square feet 15 million
square feet
250 major buildings
roughly the size of mit i think maybe a
little bigger we're sir we have a
microgrid so we can
disconnect from the grid uh and make all
our own electricity
that's optional island
typically we're connected
we have a district
steam system and a district chilled
water system
we're hooked up to the grid
uh both we're three miles out to an
interstate national gas pipeline and a
um
and the regional electric vehicle system
is an aside here um
we're in a natural gas constrained area
differently than you think of in the
northeast you can't get enough gas into
natural gas into the in the winter
months into new england well we can't
get it out we're in part of the
marcellus shale region even though
uh
high intensity fracking for natural gas
has been banned in new york state
we're so close to the gas fields of
pennsylvania
that we have very cheap natural gas and
because it's actually cheaper than
the national standard
so we take natural gas
and we take the grid we also have a
hydro plant one megawatt hydra plant
which serves uh the whole campus is a 30
megawatt load this uh hyder plant was
built in 1904 we're continuing to renew
that uh with turbine rebuilds and
control
removal in
2000 we started up late source cooling
to cool the campus
we uh it's pretty innovative project
since then the city of toronto has
followed us
and
we go 250 feet deep to where it's always
cold
in uh
the deep waters of hugo lake
and so we bypass the con
refrigerant system compressors uh we've
dropped our uh
summer load peak by it would typically
be about 45 or 50 megawatts if we had to
run conventional chillers but with this
system
which is a sustainable supply system
we're about 30 megawatts quite a
dramatic reduction
now looking forward what are we going to
do to get off natural gas if we are
continuing to drive to climate neutral
campus well one idea is solar to replace
the brown grid we've started up one
2 megawatt solar project and i'll talk
about that on another slide
we're also contracted for wind
we hope to get a local wind farm built
by others
where we would take all their output
enabling them to get their investors and
offset about 20 of our electric use
this is our big hail mary idea for
heating the campus so electricity is one
thing and um this is to go deep into the
earth and i have another slide on this
i'll just
approach these two uh future
electric with the next slide and there's
peaking biomass um for heating also
so uh solar we um
we use other people's money uh we're
going to third parties to build uh right
off campus
this is our first 2 megawatt it's about
a 10 acre solar site
it's kind of funky looking that's a
wetland
in the middle of it
and we provide long-term
power purchase agreements facility
investors have surety of their
investment return
typical right now we're working on
uh
four more of these
if we can get uh interconnections
agreement with our local utilities and
we're also as i mentioned working on a
wind farm
agreement or we've signed a wind farm
agreement and hopefully it'll get built
this is back to deep
earth heat earth source heat
this is an idea championed by professor
jeff tester who came to us from mit
he actually started working on this i
think in the late 70s in los alamos uh
in our case we would
the concept is we would drill down
almost three miles to where the earth is
hot enough to provide the heat
pump water down because it's dry this is
not the conventional hydrothermal
geothermal system
it's a dry hot rock so we would have to
pump water down
through
fractures to heat it up and then bring
it back to a heat exchanger
so right now this is a concept we're
talking to our new york state
and
about raising money just to do a
feasibility study but this would be key
to uh this is our plan a for heating the
campus in the future it's kind of a long
shot it may not work technically it may
not work uh economically and it may not
be acceptable to the community so it's
all quite interesting challenges we'd
like to
approach
so my
second last slide is a case study i just
want to throw in something about
adaptation this is
roosevelt island in the east river uh
just on the east side of manhattan we're
looking kind of east towards queens
this is a our
architectural rendering of a campus that
we hope is built like this by 2017 we've
demolished the hospital so we won a
contest many of you may be aware of it
the bloomberg sponsored to build a tech
campus to sort of diversify the economy
of new york city
what you see here is all
solar panels and the idea is to make
this first academic building
net zero energy where all the
electricity uh it's electric building so
the heat would come from ground source
heat pumps
and all the electricity would come from
on an annual basis net from the solar
panels uh
we had one set of plans that were
actually changed a little bit when
hurricane sandy came
hurricane sandy the the floodwaters came
over the seawall over the sidewalk over
the road and up up in the lawns like
right about here um
and so we raised the uh
the um
the bottom floor of these buildings
about two feet because of that so uh we
had always been cognizant that the
projections are for six foot sea level
rise this century but that brought it
home a little bit we also did
brought all our transformers above
ground so they're in uh central utility
plant high and dry
we hope for that for the long haul
i just want to put in a plug for the
pringle lakes climate fund so i did
offset my uh
now canceled airplane flight to
syracuse to boston with our local
climate fund i calculated that i would
have used
300 some pounds so it cost
or
spewed out 300 some pounds of co2
and cost about three dollars and 80
cents to offset that so
that's what i had i'll turn it back to
ann
i'll take the privilege maybe to start a
few questions but i hope there are some
out there as well
what natalie one thing that came to my
mind when you're speaking was uh you're
focused on the projections of the future
and planning for those big events
coming from my background and knowing
what goes into those scenarios and
indeed how uncertain they are and indeed
they may be below what could really
happen we may not have enough knowledge
of
our own surroundings to know how bad
things could be so do you do you build
in the safety factor do you do you take
account for the uncertainty in how
how wide you have to plan for
yes i mean the whole discussion about
earth's uncertainties was very key to
our process so they are the uh
uncertainties of climate change you know
are we under predicting or over
predicting so probably under predicting
there are also the uncertainties of the
model we use which we did downscaling so
because you have climate projection
worldwide and then what it does it mean
locally so this is where we work with uh
catherine ijo as a scientist
a climate scientist and uh but and we
add a level of uncertainties there
because of limited existing weather
station data so uh
you know this is one aspect there was
also somewhat of a clash a very
interesting one between science and
engineering in the sense that science is
very comfortable working with wide range
and so the approach was there's going to
be extreme flooding and if it's happened
in the next 20 years or in the next 70
years it doesn't matter it's going to
happen from an engineering point of view
or from a building point of view it's
huge i mean 20 years versus 70 years you
know it's what are going to be your
design standard so what we have been
doing is
we at first our climate projection with
uncertainties then we meet we met with
boston water and sewer
state agencies city of boston city of
cambridge and we compared our different
model and we came with what we thought
we we work to align our uh design storm
in some ways and so we understand the
level of uncertainties uh and we know
the trend is going to be increasing it's
how much how soon so but this is a first
step and this are very m
dynamic in the sense that they're going
to be re-assessed on uh
with each study but at some point for
the city of cambridge that's the next
step and this is daunting to them which
one to opt for so that's a bit of a long
answer but i think that is really the
struggle for the city planners they need
an absolute answer and they need it for
their time frame of of the decisions
they need to make and scientists in
general are pretty poor at being able to
supply that information on on their
terms it's a constant struggle
yes and if i one thing we are looking at
what's very helpful is looking at
critical assets so we did a study of
massport and we're doing partners as
well but this is where you say okay what
are the risks and consequences so for
example if you have some uh uh
commercial building the risk of that
building failing is probably uh mundane
or you know or if that building have a
life expectancy of 20 years what should
be your design standard if you're the
local hospital that is to be the you
know critical center for a response then
maybe you have zero tolerance for risk
there so this is where also the building
use can help you take a informed
decision your financial horizon also is
quite important or we look at for
example for a research center if you
lose 20 years of research and how what
happened to new york hospital you know
there's no room for uh tolerance there
so this is where the criticality of some
aspect can allow you to allo prioritize
funds you know and uh prioritize uh a
key decision and uh uh use time also to
help you see where you have more time
also of your building you know so this
is where you have to put all those
different parameters and help you uh
take a decision path this is where that
hazards field really helped contribute
to the climate change field in the past
several years when we were looking say
in the indus basin and colorado river
basins on a scenario-driven climate
impact assessment
you start out with your gcms and your
downscaled models and then your
hydrology and and sediment transport and
then an ecosystem and by the time you
got to any kind of policy
question the uncertainties had piled up
so high that there was little warrant
for action but when you take the
approach uh
just mentioned of starting with what are
some of the critical questions being
faced today anyway
and backing into the types of climate
analysis that can complement the
approach that you might have otherwise
taken
that's proven enormously motivating
to
everyone to be able to kind of
incorporate
climate impact assessment and
in their work
i was very happy of course to hear tony
say the money is available
we can do the
deferred maintenance because we have the
funds we just need to make the decision
on how to apply them
and i link that in with something you
said of
uh how about focusing on the outdoor the
green space and i noticed kendall square
the re the plans for that have a lot of
green which i maybe is
it was nice to see of course but i
wonder um
do you think there's a way we can
instigate uh the priority
as you suggested to to make it up in the
planning process to
to
institutionalize basically the
um
design principles of
caring about the very long term caring
about the
psycho resilience i mean the different
aspects that maybe
aren't on the table in people's minds
quite as much um in the past
yeah i actually think that that that is
is happening it's been uh great to see
what some of the killian court studies
are happening now a real kind of
terrestrial ecology
approach coming in for planting design
as well as in kendall square east campus
where
some of the ways in which the landscape
and landscape architectural consultants
are being brought in in a very kind of
prominent way there have been many
landscape architects of the past but you
really get a sense of a movement towards
environmental sustainability as a core
principle and an inspiring aspect
vis-a-vis constraint on
on design in and campus so that have the
sense that in this
current planning and building cycle that
this is going to be happening in in
really important ways that it and that
haven't been
i think it's fair to say part of the
history of campus development up until
now so this is really new territory and
if it can be linked with the types of
research and teaching that we do where
people who do hydrogeology are tracking
flow rates and groundwater levels and
the sorts of contamination that we have
i mean i like to think that we have an
optimally contaminated campus
in the sense that it's it's got
contamination from all the old
industries but not so much so that we'd
want to evacuate
you actually can measure things you can
remediate things you can have all kinds
of instrumentation of what's happening
in this landfill
and how it's weathered over the past
century all kinds of cool scientific
questions
related to environmental remediation
that could be you know part of our
laboratory here at mit
and so i get the sense that both
great things are happening but
even an order of magnitude more is
possible
because the other angle i wanted to get
out a bit was
a comment you made about not wanting to
adapt but to have planned
to not need adaptation but
how can you
foresee what's coming and not and and
take off the the
the need to adapt yeah i actually think
adaptation is a misnomer i mean it's if
you ask do
human beings adapt
by intention
i i i don't think that that's quite uh
sound
conceptually because uh adaptation is an
exposed judgment people proved adaptive
or they didn't what people do is is it
is what a mentor that i had gilbert
white he used to speak of human
adjustment
to
changing environmental conditions and
hazards and adjustment is something
where you act with the hope of being
adaptive which you won't find out
until later so adjustment then opens up
a real
uh sense of creative possibilities uh
that the adaptive solution is not
necessarily singular but uh wide open
and it has to be assessed and reassessed
continuously through the exposed
evaluation of things that we've already
done
and so
adaptation one tries to mitigate that is
to
act in advance and not require
adjustments to
the actual experience of a disaster or
hazard but
that's not possible either one has to be
prepared and one has to be prepared to
adjust in all kinds of ways and
possibilities and even to things that
you don't want to think about
uh with the hope that they'll prove
adaptive over the long run
interesting twist on the lexicon there
yeah
climate change colleagues aren't happy
with that idea no that's fine you also
use mitigation in a different form form
than the standard used in the climate
side that's correct yeah in the hazards
field it's just
maybe i'll put in a plug for a
communications event we're planning for
the
climate change conversation committee is
putting on
an event on march 31st about why is it
so difficult to talk about climate
change and communicate uh the threat and
the issues surrounding it and we've
given a couple examples right here on we
use the same words to mean different
things in different fields and the
example that was given on risk and
hazard
was risk equals hazard types
vulnerability the hazards people say
hazard equal risk times vulnerability
and the engineering field the same kind
of
dual usage of the of these terms but
they're easy to sort out if you're in
the field
so i don't want to forget about you bert
i was interested in a comment you made
about um carbon neutrality and how would
you get there from here
in this morning session uh which i don't
think you were listening in on but
one theme that came up a few times was a
lack of
collective lack of imagination of how
are we going to get there and what will
the future look like
it seems that cornell has put a lot of
thought into
trying many different
potential ways to get to that carbon
neutrality
as it's commendable and i don't see
not i'm no expert in this field but i
don't see that mit has quite as many
options on the table uh perhaps i we
don't have a lot of 10-acre uh fields
nearby where we can put a lot of
solar panels on but
it's interesting can you say a bit about
um
where these ideas have come from for
your group
is it a collective
uh effort uh um
is it from top down is it the students
who started the movement at the
beginning i mean how did these ideas
surface
i talked about the occupy day hall that
was 2001. in 2007 when the president's
climate commitment was offered up by
second nature
the students i think there's about 4 000
signatures on a petition to to commit
uh we in the staff wrote a white our
staff and faculty collaborated because
the president and the provost want to
know well does this make any sense
and
if i can think back to the white paper
it was more like
we said well
we don't know how we're going to exactly
get to climate neutrality
we think
you should commit and we'll figure it
out as we go
because that's what society has to do
so
as we
as he signed the president's climate
commitment and we wrote our first
climate action plan
in and filed it i think in 2009
we actually opened it up we had an idea
of you know
generation
meetings we had open houses we kept logs
on the computer of all the ideas
so it was yeah there was quite a wide
net cast for
ideas on how to proceed uh towards
climate new
neutrality
and resulted in their first climate
action plan in 2009 our updates since
then we've updated every other year and
we're actually updating it this year um
are a little more perfunctory and
sometimes not as inclusive uh but i
think this time because of the
acceleration we're going to be more
inclusive and less engineering i i just
wouldn't want to stress that i think
it's just
the challenge is is enormous to get off
fossil fuels and cheap fossil fuels now
because of uh
natural gas is so cheap
the challenge to change the
infrastructure over is enormous and it
it really uh
it can't just be left us in facilities
or engineers to do uh we're really
hoping the academics step up and they
are actually uh we're involving our
faculty and a number quite engaged any
thoughts or comments you want to raise
way in the back sure
hi first of all thank you uh
all of you for those insightful comments
i sort of have a follow-up question uh
jeremy poindexter here um
related to uh what was just discussed
which is
um in in sort of my discussions with
some of the people in this room and my
advisor and my fellow students
and discussing how mit can implement
solutions and sustainability
uh a common theme that has come up is
well how can we do this not only you
know copying or
being inspired by things
that other people have done but
implement them in a way that is unique
to mit
this and this idea of
applying things um in the mit way really
has grabbed uh has i think people latch
on to
and so
uh i guess that's sort of just a general
comment and maybe people can think about
that for brainstorming for this section
um but
i'd like to throw that out to the panel
um who has a variety of different
backgrounds and perspectives both inside
and outside of mit can you think of of
any ways that we could do things
like those that have been discussed in a
a way that's unique to this institute
that's a great great question and one of
the uh questions that's uh
very much uh
central in the uh kendall square
development is you know what's the
mitness of this space and what it will
make it
uh part of the culture of mit as a
a campus
design and a place of continuous
experimentation and learning so that i
think that's squarely
on topic with what you've mentioned i've
taken those some all of uh of the
complete opposite approach in in classes
as well and
part of what we did when we were looking
at the kendall square was to say what
what lessons can you learn from other
parts of the world
that might be relevant here uh because
in much of the 20th century mit
mi the us saw itself as an exporter of
knowledge purely as an exporter in the
19th century we were importing and
adapting knowledge in the 21st century i
think there's going to be all kinds of
flows very different from the 20th
century mentality you make it here and
you export it you commercialize it
elsewhere would love and so it was
really exciting to see people taking
ideas from india on rainwater harvesting
that were profound not just functional
but really profound in how they fit the
cultures there and asked you know what
would that be like here and
we asked students to think what
what's the where's the the walden at mit
i mean to the kind of counterpoint to an
mit culture so you get to actually
challenge the mit ness and that can
perceive cultures at mit as well as to
advance them it's just a
response to your idea of jeremy i think
it's a really good question
i have a very selfish
concern about what mit is about and what
would be interested is in our research
for the city of cambridge and you know
other cities there's that what i call
the fourth dimension which is the
virtual dimension and this is about data
one of the uncertainties is about the
lack of data for a temperature for
example or even and uh we've been
following what mit is doing and even
there was you know there's a someone
from the co-lab you know which is about
that virtual room for discussing and
there's some research done about
networking when sandy happened what was
a key factor was how people connect
via their
telephone and there's app basically and
this is something where mit is really at
the forefront and always has been and
this is something this is data driven i
mean sustainability and climate change
and there's the collective very
democratization of data as well and so
this is something that would be so
helpful to inform some of our work and i
don't know if academia has been
contributing but uh you know there could
be something unique here yeah i think
it's happening in on campus in the
energy field with all this kind of data
uh analytics on the energy and and to
push it into the water sphere would be a
natural extension and to be having
actual you could have plasma flow
readings of who's using how much water
all over the campus and be able to
manage it much more effectively real
time near real time there's all kinds of
cool ways in which that idea could
really push forward
i think broadening it just a bit to
realize that cambridge itself is fairly
unique
as a cultural center
and
the thought also that part of why mit
should
i
my opinion should take a step forward in
this realm is to
show how it can be done and so if you
focus too much on the uniqueness of a
solution that mit can
make happen
maybe it's not as generalizable
so just a word of caution to to be too
concerned about doing it a way only mit
could do
sitting
in upstate new york i'm continually
amazed by the mit
research and the the reports mit puts
out their comprehensive thorough not
just you know the journal paper but
these reports on
issues around
climate change climate modeling energy
the resources there are fantastic and i
just want to see that continue and and
hope even more so you know i think
certainly climate change the crisis is
one of the
uh
defining if not the defining issue of
this
century anyway and um i think it's just
great what mit is doing and just keep
doing and do more of it
thanks bert
is there another question out there
comment
yep sure thinking about how when we talk
about building technologies we have
something to measure against building
code or ashrae standards or something
that's
quantifiable and that if you improve on
that you have you can look at the
payback and and the life cycle and so
forth in the case of open space natural
systems vegetation
it's a little bit um
it's not quite as clear yet about how we
measure those things and how we say how
we talk about what the quantifiable
benefits are beyond the
the kind of softer elements of the
landscape that are
an improvement but they're a little bit
harder sell perhaps in terms of
you know from just looking at strictly
how is this going to contribute to our
climate changes are we
saying that x number of trees is a
carbon offset to a new building
technology can you help us think about
um can you help us think about that
issue a little bit a couple of concrete
examples you take the uh
east cambridge has been going through
sewer separation
uh past you know years and and uh almost
to the point of sewer separation where
uh even though we're going to have fewer
combined sewer overflows into the
charles river we're going to have a
direct loading of all of the storm water
and to the river that was formerly some
portion of which went to treatment
plants so that means the loading of all
kinds of contaminants including the
phosphorus that's of special concern
is going to come up and that could be a
really
very
explicit uh
uh kind of measured uh criterion of any
kind of campus uh
green infrastructure to go in is
phosphorus reduction for which one could
get credits
the second great example is is insofar
as one can
reduce the
increase infiltration reduce the
stormwater discharge through green
infrastructure it can reduce your
building
uh costs for detention and subsurface
cisterns and so on so there's a another
trade-off that could be
part and i think it already is a part of
a lot of analyses of of new building
projects
the you mentioned some of the
microclimatic benefits of trees and
vegetation not to be
under
estimated what tree canopy can do in all
kinds of very subtle ways and i think
cultivating a sense of the subtlety of
environmental experience again as to
what's you know a really comfortable
space and what's
uncomfortable will be
you know it's it's not been as necessary
with air conditioning and other types of
interventions but if that can be
cultivated in people would be enormous
in terms of psychological benefits and i
don't think we should shy away or treat
soft things as soft anymore uh you know
the kinds of
experiential and psychological and
social if we look at what our community
says is most important in the way of
resilience it's these psychological and
social dimensions which we don't measure
with respect to environmental
interventions
nearly as rigorously as other types of
benefits so get the
types of work in cognitive sciences and
psychophysiology
to work on this and we might find just
extraordinary uh benefits that can be
quantified by different types of space
and design and stress reduction which
all of us would pay a fortune for a
little bit of that and not doing
necessarily bert more of the same as
we were kind of at a threshold sometimes
for the city of cambridge uh what we
realize looking at projected flooding in
terms of depth and boundaries is that uh
they they won't be it won't be possible
to engineer out of the flooding so it
has to be a combination of green
infrastructure and standard engineering
and we looked at oboken who was able to
get an epa waiver using a maximization
of projected green infrastructure and
that included green roof green street
combined with their standard
more traditional engineering to show
that how much the green infrastructure
was contributing to a storm water
management and this is a will be a model
for the city of cambridge i remember
mentioning to uh colleagues in the
netherlands oh we only have you know
several feet down to groundwater in our
campus we have a very shallow water
table and they said what are you talking
shallow we work with centimeters you
know
storage
it brings to mind a comment this morning
i was speaking with israel over coffee
about
closing down the campus for the the
snowstorms uh recently because this is
in recent memory this has been very
unusual year but in the old days the
campus didn't close during snowstorms
and of course the reason why they did
this year is really had nothing to do
with mit but primarily to do with the
tea
and the governor calling declaring
emergency so it's the infrastructure
that's not within our
our our control that is uh controlling
our productivity in a sense
an interesting comment that you made
that in these days of webex why would we
need to close campus we could all dial
in from home and continue classes and
operate most of us couldn't telecommute
and do our jobs from wherever we happen
to be
um could that become a priority
instituted in our our culture here to to
not need to be present
just a thought all right thank you again
for the participants and everybody
you